[Music]
Uh, Mr. Gordon Moore, who was a
professor at Mitcham in the
1960s, discovered that between 1962 and 1965,
the performance of
electronic components had increased significantly.
He extrapolated from this, saying it
was a law and that it would
always be true. So, let's say
the simple statement is that the
performance of electronic components
increases exponentially with a
time constant of approximately two years,
meaning they triple
in two years. What this means,
stated in 1965, is still
true, and that's quite
extraordinary. If it's true, it's because
when manufacturers
of components became aware of
the existence of Moore's Law around
1990-1995, they adopted it as a
criterion for their investments.
So, at that point, Moore's Law, instead of
being a mere observation, became the
foundation of progress. And we are still there.
In
2012, well, that's still true, but
as you pointed out,
we're not able to
grasp what a
2-year time constant is. A
2-year time constant is fantastically fast; it's never
happened in the history of the
world that technology has advanced at
such a speed. And we don't have an
assimilation capacity that's on
the order of a
generation. It takes a
generation to truly assimilate a
major technological advancement, and that
generation is 30 years between
parents and children, so a difference
of between 2 and 30 years. And the result is
that the entire global social structure
is
[Music]
turned upside down. We have to ask ourselves what we
should do today. We
have a world that's moving towards
universal connectivity, meaning
everyone is connected to everyone else,
and that's truly
mysterious. We don't really know how to
manage it at the moment.
Very poor populations and
Wealthy populations, those who remain
extremely distant, tend
to converge through collection. So what does that
mean? That's it, that's it, that's the
mystery, the mystery of
our
time. I classify populations according to
their
income. Developed populations
have €100 per day per person,
poor populations have €1 per
day per person. I've just returned from a trip,
a mission to Haiti, a country of 100
million inhabitants. 60% of the people have
one dollar per day. We live in
France, in a country where the
average is around 80. On average, that
means there are some
poor people, let's say 5% of the population, who
are poor. But on average,
we are 100 times above the level
of Haiti, and yet the people of Haiti
speak to us, or at least they receive
our message. They receive our
message of
consumption. How? Because
everyone watches television, and on
television, what do we see? Well,
we see people in superb
cars with lots of advertising. I
watched the  Television there shows a lot
of advertising for rich people's products,
and there are the poor people, the
people who have nothing, who don't even have a
house because it was destroyed by
the land machine, and yet they live virtually
in the world of the rich. It's
the connection that is
truly the
new phenomenon. So when you talk about
ethics, well, we don't
really know what to do, and uh, I don't
think we can continue. That's
the subject of my book of the century,
threats. We can't continue like
this, it won't continue like this. You
have a common theme among all the
world's political classes, which
is the method, uh, to, for example, get
out of the crisis: growth.
So, that's the common theme:
growth. Currently, we
have significant growth in the so-called
emerging economies, around 5-6%,
even 10% per year in China, but 5-6% pretty much
everywhere. And then much
weaker growth in
developed countries because they're reaching their limits.  It can't go any
further with the law of
maximum growth, well known to
all economists, and we see that there can't be
growth
exceeding 1 or 2% in
developed countries, no matter what our
leaders say, regardless of their political affiliation.
This growth, even if it's only
1 or 2% per year,
applies to a finite world, a world with very, very
limited resources. So, when you
have,
say, a crocodile inside a closed container, growing and wanting to
eat more and more, and there's
a finite number of ducks
inside the container, something will inevitably happen to the crocodile once
all the ducks have been
eaten.
That's for sure. All of this was
beautifully expressed mathematically in a
famous book by Vittorio Volterra, published around 1910. It
could be called "
Lessons on the Struggle for Life," where he
reasoned about soils and sharks
in a closed sea. So, you have...
Sharks that eat the soil, well,
when there's more soil, the number of
sharks decreases, and then, since
the sharks decrease, the amount of soil
increases, and so the two
systems also interact there. So you
have very well integral equations, what we call
soil equations, which
describe the problem very well.
But if you're in a
finite world, you've eaten all the soil, and there are no more sharks.
We're in
this system.
[Music]
Yes, that's what I don't want to
predict, and I'm not for
the apocalypse or for
catastrophe. I'm simply saying, here's the
situation, it's very simple: you have
a finite quantity of resources, and
this finite quantity will be
consumed at some point. Well, at that point, we don't
know where it is. And
so there's a
lot of controversy,
people who say, "No, not at all, it'll all work out."
So we say, "Man has
always managed," that's the
classic reasoning, we've always
found solutions. We'll
So, people
who have been talking about this are mistaken; the
controversy is there, but I believe it's
not true for several reasons.
Firstly,
we are in an
unprecedented situation. We can't say that
humanity has always managed to get by.
Today, that's not true. The law of
death is something new, a
constant of two years. It's something
new because this
technological progress corresponds to
increased consumption, and
this consumption goes with
growth of, let's say, at least 2%. 2%
per year is enormous. If there were a
constant of 100 years, it would
n't be a problem, but a constant of
two years, well, that's where
the problem lies. The second error in
this reasoning, for me, is even more
serious: science and technology will
provide us with solutions. I
gave a very good example that just
happened. We were talking about the depletion of
oil, called P-Oil, and well, no, that's not
true because there has been a major
discovery.  The technique that has just been
developed is hydrofracking, and
hydrofracking allows us to multiply
reserves, so we won't run out
of oil. Well,
I think there are perhaps
two errors in this kind of
reasoning. The first is that
even
hydrofracking provides
new resources, but not
many. Even if we find a very
large, very rich oil basin,
it will only correspond
to 10 days of world consumption.
World consumption is, let's say, 90 million
barrels per day. If we find a
10 billion barrel deposit, we find that
extraordinary, etc. That's not the case. The same
judgment we saw in Guyana,
which we're talking about a lot, is between 1 and 5.
So what does that mean?
80 million barrels per day is 3
billion per year. And so if you have a huge 5
billion barrel deposit, that's 2 months, 1/6 of a year. Okay,
so let's find 10 million barrels, that's...  That's quite a lot,
10, well, 10 makes,
uh, 5
years, and so, and so the magnitude of the
problem is
underestimated when we talk about
new resources. B, that's, that's, that's
the first mistake, but a much more fundamental mistake is what, that's what, sums it up in
one sentence, is that more
productivism or consumerism cannot
cure the ills of consumerism.
And I'll
give a few examples, for instance, with
automobiles, you've had
very significant progress in the
last 30 years in
fuel consumption, and
we can say that now, uh, instead
of
8 liters of gasoline per 100 km, we consume
5 on average. That's huge. With large
investments, we can really say
great success, well,
gasoline consumption hasn't
decreased, it's increased, and for a
very simple reason: from the
moment you have a car that
consumes less, it's cheaper, so
it becomes accessible to
poorer people, and so these people are more
numerous. With more cars
running, you have twice as many  of the
car you had when the engines were
malfunctioning, so the technical program didn't generate
savings, but on the
contrary, an
increase in fuel consumption.
So, I'm giving this
as an example, to give many other
examples. You have to understand that this won't work if
you find a hydrofracking system.
Well, what does that mean? It means that
gasoline in the United States becomes
cheaper, and that's what we're seeing: the
price at the pump is decreasing in the United States
because of
hydrofracking. Well, there will be more
people using more cars,
and the result will be higher fuel consumption.
And hydrofracking,
well, it will have brought, let's say,
10 years, 1500, of respite, but on
the scale I'm considering, that is, 2050,
between 2050 and
2100, well, it only makes
the
situation worse.
[Music]
Yes, this leads to some
very complicated considerations, which I will nevertheless go into.
We see that
oil discoveries have been
lower than consumption since 1980-90, so
when we say that reserves remain
constant, it's not true;
they decrease. Therefore, we will be forced
to use oil in places that are
more expensive to deforest and
exploit. So, the certain
consequence—I'm not
talking about an oil shortage, that's
possible—
is an increase in price.
So, that's for sure, as you
very rightly say, the price of oil will
increase. And now I'd like to start
a very
simple discussion about some consequences,
especially agricultural ones. Back in
1960, we all thought there would be a
food shortage
in the world, and that didn't happen. It didn't
happen because there was
something the Indians invented
called the Green Revolution.
The Green Revolution consists
of increasing irrigation and, above all,
increasing the use of
fertilizers.  This is what we call NPK:
nitrogen, phosphorus,
potassium. And
indeed, this policy has prevented
any famine. We can say, as a first
approximation, that there hasn't been any famine since 1960. There hasn't been any
famine from time to
time. Well, there are parts of the world that don't have enough; there are
a billion
people who don't have enough to eat, we
know that. But there's no universal family,
especially in large,
populated countries like India or
China. Let's look at what NPK is.
Nitrogen: 1 kg of nitrogen (in gray) equals 1 kg
of
oil. Yes, you need 1 kg
of nitrogen, 1 kg of oil for 1 kg
of nitrogen. So, when you say that,
you see the impact, the
extremely serious impact of
the increase in the price of oil. And
besides, when there's an increase in the
price of oil, like in 2008, you have a
famine because farmers can no longer
buy
fertilizer. And that's the kind of
consideration that completely escapes the public,
yet...  It's not
complicated, and besides, we can
make the same kind of
remarks regarding
other components, like
potassium.
Potash mines are being depleted; there are
some very large
potash mines, but again, like
oil, the price will increase. So not
only will the price of oil
fertilizers increase, but also the price of
potassium fertilizers. And finally,
regarding phosphate, there are
mines that are being
overexploited. From 2003 onwards,
global oil production will start
to decline and will fall to a
maximum of 1.3 trillion by the end of the century. So that means
that the three
main ingredients of the Green Revolution will
see their prices increase, and that means that
farmers will suffer
and suffer because they will see the
price of fertilizers increase so much that
they won't be able to
buy them anymore. For me, that's a
typical shortage that has been
completely ignored. People say, "No, we'll know how to
feed the
population." In fact, the people who say we'll know how to
population add, "On the condition."  that we no
longer eat meat, provided we no
longer eat meat, because meat,
and especially beef, is
extremely costly in terms of water and
resources in general. It takes, I don't know,
1000 times more water
for 1 kg of beef than for 1 kg of wheat, and
so, uh, we can't, we won't be able to, with
the current growth in
meat consumption, especially in China,
well, we won't be able to support
agriculture. But you see,
to summarize all this, there's something
that really struck me. Three
years ago, I was invited by the Chinese Academy of
Sciences to spend some
time in Beijing
to evaluate a large
Chinese space laboratory. So, I don't know if I
immersed myself in the
daily life of Chinese researchers for a
while, a little over a month, to write
this fascinating report, by the way. And so, I think I finally
understood what
China's major long-term objective is, as
defined by the Chinese Academy of Sciences in
well-
thought-out documents. The objective  China's goal is to
become a moderately developed country by 2050.
What does "moderately
developed" mean? So I tried to
understand by thinking we need to translate
that quantitatively. There are
people who live on one dollar a day, people who live on
100 dollars a day, very good. But
let's suppose the goal is for China to be moderately developed. Let's say the
average is 40
dollars a day. And the Chinese
today, how many dollars a day? They live
on 6. So that means we need to
multiply the consumption of the Chinese today by between 6 and 8
to get the
consumption of the Chinese in 2050.
And yes, we need to think about that.
We can naturally imagine that the
Indians have the same goal. So that means there are
three, let's say on
the order of 3 billion
people whose consumption will be
multiplied by 6. That's not
sustainable. So we're at 7
billion. It's not sustainable at 7
billion. Everyone agrees that
in 2050 we  Going to 9 isn't certain,
but it's not true, it's not
9 billion. You have to
take the 3 billion from the nine who
are Chinese and Indian and
multiply by 5 or something like
that, and so that makes 15.
Roughly, a simple calculation
shows you that at that point you
fall between 20 and 25 billion
people. So that means that,
very roughly, schematically,
global consumption will be multiplied by
3, on the order of 20 or 25, compared to what it
is today.
[Music]
7.
Shortages will be aggravated by science
and technology, contrary to what we
think. So we are faced with
a problem where resources
are consumed too
quickly, and the methods that have
increased this consumption—
science and technology—will only
increase it. So it's not in that
direction that we should look to find
a solution to our future problems.
A second possibility would be to
appeal to  A political governance,
for example, with a super UN that would
decide that no one in the world can
consume more than 1 liter of gasoline
per day, something like that, or
1 kilogram of bread per day per year—so a
world government that would enact
rules to prevent
overconsumption—everyone knows that doesn't
work; it's not a
solution. We saw that
last year with the
Copenhagen conference, but we see it every day.
And to clearly
understand the fallacy of this approach, one only needs
to quote President
Bush, the father: "The
standard of living in the United States is
not negotiable."
And this is
true for all governments.
If you address the President of the
French Republic, he will say: "The standard
of living of the French is not negotiable; it
must increase, but it cannot
decrease." So, all
governments, as soon as the
supply of vital resources is affected,
are the same.  Don't
touch it, so that
means it's not
possible to lower the standard of living, it
's not possible to reduce
consumption through politics, and I
'm ready to discuss this with anyone
and win any bet. It's
not possible. And when
people were
surprised last year by the failure of the
Copenhagen conference, well, that proves they had
n't thought it through at all. Because what happened? There are
jokers like the
Europeans who came to say, "Oh, we
have to pay close attention to the climate," and
then there are serious people like the
Americans, the Chinese, the Russians who came
and told us, "Just
tell us stories, there's no
climate change," even though their
scientists say there is.
But the politicians said it's not happening, period. That's the end of it. The
conference stopped. The other
conference in Ry was the same thing,
but naturally, all of this was
disguised as rhetoric. So, neither
science nor technology nor politics—
what's left?  So, that's it, that's how
I reasoned, at least. Well, I've noticed
that there are eating habits,
for example, I'll take this as an example, that
are
codified by religions. For instance,
Hindu religions forbid the
consumption of meat. There's
no meat consumption in
India, and there isn't for reasons
we'll call spiritual or religious.
But this also existed in the
Middle Ages; there was Lent, for a
month, when you couldn't eat meat. And
besides, for the Catholic Church, on
Fridays, you don't eat meat, and
people accepted this very willingly.
Why? Because baby Jesus
had said so. So there's a
potential for action there, trying to use
religious motivations to
change these habits.  And I think there's no
paradox in that, it's
really true, it's how it is,
you can change the walls through
religious considerations, and so you have to
address the people who
command, let's say,
who command religions, and
for that you have to address
religions that are structured, where there is
a leader, there's only one really, the
Catholic Church. The Catholic Church, what does it have? It has
a leader, it has
troops, it has a structure, a
hierarchy, a habit of, let's
say, obedience.
Obedience, a very
Catholic word. So why not
address the Catholic Church, which has
a billion faithful? And if it were
convinced, well, it will convince
others through
negotiations, for example. I'm told that
the Orthodox Church is currently sensitive
to this kind of
consideration, whatever one
thinks of the Orthodox Church. Well,
why not mobilize it too? And
so this reasoning led me to
address...  The Catholic Church, by
asking him, "Can't you convince yourself
that we
are in a perilous situation and
that you can do something about it?"
[Music]
Not at all, I'm not resigned.
Scientifically, since I believe, as
I explained, that
the action of science and technology
goes in a certain direction, and in that direction, for
almost my entire life I
admired it. I agreed, I found it
extremely good, and that's partly why I was a
scientist. Part of the reason I was a
scientist is that there were benefits for all of
humanity; it increased their
standard of living. And so, and that's
true, but what happened is that the
machine went haywire, and now
it's gone haywire because of its
internal engines. The main point is
very difficult. Let's say there are
two trends: on the one hand, the
demographic trend of an increasing population, and on the other hand,
another trend, which
is the increase in needs.  Everyone wants
more, everyone
wants more, but nobody
thought about it when I was 2 years old.
Nobody thought the machine
would run away with it, nobody
thought the world's population
would double in 30
years, something monstrous, going from 3
to 7 billion suddenly like that in a
few decades.
[Music]
Absolutely, you're right, but it's going to
continue. So, well,
I'm willing to admit there's a
saturation point in
population growth, but the figure of 9
billion is absolutely certain,
maybe 9.5 and 10 billion by the
end of the century, right? We say it's going to
decrease after that, but it's not true, it's going to, it's not going to reach saturation
in 2050, it's going to continue to
increase, much more slowly. Anyway,
I've explained everything, that
these 9 or 10 billion aren't
the problem because at the same time,
needs are increasing because
people want more, and so it's not 9
billion we should be thinking about, but
20, that's something we couldn't have
imagined at all, and that
you can't imagine either.
People your age don't think that there will be
three times as many
people to feed as there are now, and that therefore water
consumption and so on will
increase. You have a country like
Yemen, I like to talk about Yemen, there are
25 million inhabitants, 22
million inhabitants in Yemen now,
in 2050 the population will have doubled.
So the question to ask is what is the
level of the water table, that's what
's interesting, there aren't any
other questions to ask. So this water
table was at 10 meters 30 years ago,
today it's 1 kilometer deep, now at... well, we pump it with
subsidized pumps, down the
subsidized pumps we go down to 1000 meters, well, that's it, at
1000 meters there's nothing at
all. So that means this
population of 45 million  With 0
liters of water per day, what's
going to happen?
But you don't think about that. It's
not the kind of problem you ask yourself.
When we talk about the Middle East, we
talk about the stones of Jerusalem. It shouldn't matter. What's
important is the water supply, the water
supply of Palestine, which is approaching
zero. I go to India. I've
worked a lot in India. I see
cities like Madras, which is now called
Shenile. When I started going to
India 40 years ago, it had 500,000
inhabitants. Today it has 5 million. When
I go to Shenaia, I ask my friends where
the water level is. I go next door
to Ade, exactly the same situation.
Now, 5 million inhabitants. Your
water supply is no longer there. So
how do you manage? You have tens of
millions of inhabitants, there's no more
water. At that point, you have conflict.
So I wrote in the century
The threats we're not prepared for include
weapons of mass destruction. There are
two categories: one that
everyone thinks about, which
may not happen, and another that no one thinks about, which
will
undoubtedly happen. The one everyone thinks about
is
nuclear weapons. So you saw
Iran, the Iranian atom, emerge on the world stage. Well, if it hadn't
been in Iran, it would have been in
the North or Pakistan, and
so on. The location doesn't matter. What's
interesting is the cause, the
way it happens. It's the
frustrations created by the
contrast between poor and
rich countries. The poor countries have become aware of this, that's the
new awareness. They feel
frustrated, dominated, and
mocked. This
trend towards the Spirit—let's call it
spiritualism—can we
channel it to make it something
usable? That's what I thought.
To deal with the
Catholic Church, I think I was wrong,
that the Catholic Church will see me... it will make me... it will make me... it will make me look
ridiculous,
okay? But as for,
for example, Islamic countries,
well, we seem to be heading towards...
towards... weapons of
mass destruction. Okay, so
the second category of weapons of
mass destruction is biological.
Everyone knows that it's a weapon that has been
used a little bit once,
but it has tremendous potential. "
Terrific" means, you know, in
Latin "form" means fear, so "terrific"
means terrifying, not amazing,
it means
frightening. And the potential of
biological weapons is tremendous, but I do
n't want to talk about it more because it's
a subject in itself.
So there's one that
I really like called "The Number
and the Dream," which was published in 1983 and
is about the history of science, and, uh,
I don't want to... it's full of a
certain number  of new
and paradoxical analyses, and it was well received. I would like it to
continue to be well received; it has a legacy,
moreover. But, uh, the books
you want me to refer to—uh, there are
two. The first, uh,
is a
book written with Father Jacques Arnou, a
Dominican, and it came about because
Father Arnou didn't like the
previous book I had written, *The History
of the Centuries of the Century: An Introduction to the
Century of Threats*. He told me, "My
conclusion was, 'There's
nothing to be done, humanity is heading for disaster,
and there's nothing we can do about it.'" So he
told me, "You don't have the right
to write that." And so
we decided to have a
debate, in the medieval sense of the term,
since he was a Dominican,
why not?
In this book, we analyzed
the evolution as I described it
in the interviews we just had,
and we concluded that perhaps we
could
address...  to the Catholic Church, and that's what
the book is about. It actually
ends with a series
of presentations on a subject that's very important to me:
human wickedness. I give three examples of
human wickedness that are hard to read,
very, very hard to read. The first is what
the Germans call the Z Commandos,
the
extermination camps. The second is the
Medungsung Cultural Revolution,
with some emphasis on the students
who ate their teachers, their
cannibal students. This is still happening in Paris, by the way. And
the
third is the way we
treat animals. This is
really a subject that's very close to my
heart and that's completely ignored
by everyone, by the
book's readers, who shy away from
the last ten pages where
I explain, with figures and
information that are
officially given, how we treat
billions of animals,
from chickens to pigs,
including cows, in abominable conditions.
allow us to savor our soft-
boiled egg in the morning, and if we
really thought about how those soft-boiled
eggs were
obtained, well, we wouldn't be able to
eat them. I can tell you that it's a
subject that's so completely obscured that no
one has noticed that there are about
fifteen pages on this topic, with
figures in the rain, in my
book. That struck me, all the same. And
besides, some people who had
the courage to read my book told me they couldn't finish it.
And
yet, and
yet everything in there is completely
official in my latest book, which is
called "Action, Sister of Dreams." Why
this title? Well, it's a quote from
Brøler. Yes,
I will leave this world where action is not
the sister of dreams. That's where
the title comes from. And I think the
opposite, at least in my life,
and I think that many of my actions have
come from—I wouldn't say from dreams, I don't really like
the word "dream"—well, let's
say from
irrational preoccupations, obviously.  The
clearest example is the one that
shaped a large part of my
scientific life: the dream, the real dream I had
in
1967 about exploring Venus,
exploring Venus by balloon, which is
the subject of my first
book, *Venus Unveiled*. I had
a dream where I imagined—I imagined—
I saw a
point of light at the edge of a
bright circle, and this point of light, also,
its intensity... I woke up and
I thought—I can't tell you
why—a balloon, the atmosphere of
Venus, and two circles, one with a
quiosile. In my mind, this translates
to a balloon at Venus. That's
the typical example of a dream for me. And I
succeeded; I succeeded in placing two
balloons in the atmosphere of
Venus. It took me 18 years, ultimately. It's not very long.
You're... pardon, you're... ah yes, ah yes,
I'm very... yes, yes,
but  That's why I don't want to do
space research anymore,
because I know that every project takes
at least 18 years. But then,
in action, getting out of the dream, it's true that
a number of
things I've done came from, let's say, desires, from considerations that were
more
or less irrational.
For example,
satellite education, which occupies me a lot at
the moment. For example, Haiti, it's a
dream, a dream of one of my Indian friends
who was quite remarkable. He
created the Indian Space. He's been dead for a long time,
and he had this idea,
which has become a reality. And
so, it seems to me that the problem,
naturally, is that many people have
dreams that are foolish. When I say
foolish, I mean that they will lead to
nothing, and most of mine are foolish;
most have led to very little.
But it still seems necessary to
choose, among these dreams, those that have the
strongest
component of reality. And so, I believe
that in life, to succeed in life, you have to
Choosing from your dreams those with
the
potential to bring about something, that's what it
takes to move from dream to reality, that's life, that's what
[Music]
life